as Americans prepare to celebrate
Independence Day a fourth of July
tradition faces a potential threat the
majority of fireworks sold in the u.s.
are manufactured in China but a trade
war between the two countries may cause
prices to skyrocket Adriana Diaz is on
Chicago's lakefront near where the city
will set off its pyrotechnic display
next week Adriana what are the concerns
for the firework industry well Toni good
morning as the as a fourth of July it
gets closer that's all abraded here over
Lake Michigan fears that tariffs can
affect future shows are setting in
fireworks companies are worried that
tariffs could drive up prices and drive
down sales
as america prepares to ring in its
birthday with a bang a trade war with
China could shut down the party how many
of these products come from China
all of our products are produced in
China skip McCall manages the store for
phantom fireworks the country's largest
consumer fireworks retailer do you think
it could affect your livelihood if these
tariffs are applied oh I think it will
I'm more I worry more about our
employees so how many people do you
employ this time of year word max were
probably around 3,000 nationwide Bruce
Alden is phantom CEO and at this 1.2
million square foot warehouse in
Youngstown Ohio the shelves are packed
with exploding novelties
all have traveled halfway around the
world from China but as president Trump
proposes tariffs of up to 25% on all
Chinese products domestic fireworks
sales could fizzle we depend on China
for a lot of importance of a lot of
products Gregg it is the Wall Street
Journal's chief economics commentator he
says the prices of goods like fireworks
are volatile because there aren't any
american-made substitutes a lot of the
stuff we import from China are is only
made in China and so American importers
they can absorb the class themselves or
they can pass the costs on to their
customers so even if the price goes up
by 25% for example you'll still buy Wow
so why does my glass oh my goodness
that worries Bruce Alden who hopes China
and the u.s. reach an agreement before
tariffs blow up his bottom line
it's my opinion that there's good
they're going to make a deal I'm
guessing but I'm also praying this is
prayer for you it is here's a fun fact
fireworks were actually invented in
China more than a thousand years ago
actually member from my time being based
there seeing the big role they play in
celebrations like Chinese New Year so we
asked phantom CEO why not make fireworks
here he said it could take a decade for
the u.s. to catch up with China's
efficient fireworks production Anthony
Adriana thank you I always look at those
warehouses and think what happens if
they don't
yeah I know it's right if the prices go
up because these tariffs I mean I think
Americans on the 4th of July are gonna
Chicagoans are gonna be like we want
those fireworks maybe what it costs they
are the fourth that's right